bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
un peu d'informatique et on va voir
comment des règles très simples peuvent
parfois engendrer des comportements
vraiment complexe
alors quand je dis comportements
complexes je parle pas de vous derrière
votre écran d'ordinateur un an
on va parler d'une toute petite
simulation informatique vraiment très
étonnante qu'on appelle la fourmigue
langton
la fourmi de langton c'est un petit
programme informatique qui a été imaginé
par un chercheur américain qui s'appelle
chris langton alors pour simuler la
fourmi langton on va avoir besoin d'une
grille dont les cases peuvent être
blanche ou noire
et puis on va imaginer que sur une des
cases de la grille on pose une petite
fourmi et que cette fourmi elle va
pouvoir se déplacer sur les différentes
cases les règles de déplacement de la
fourmi elles sont extrêmement simples
elles se déplacent en fonction de la
couleur de la casse sur laquelle elle se
trouve
si elle est sur une case blanche elle
tourne à droite et avance et si elle est
sur une case noire elle tourne à gauche
et avance et on ajoute comme règles
supplémentaires qu'au moment où elle
quitte sa case elle en inverse la
couleur donc je répète les règles un
case blanche on va à droite cases noires
on va à gauche et dans tous les cas on
inverse la couleur de la casse continue
alors on va voir ce que ça donne si on
s'amuse à appliquer ces règles de
déplacement de manière répétée pour
faire simple on va partir d'une grille
qui est initialement complètement
blanche
et puis on va mettre la fourmi au milieu
alors premier mouvement la fourmi elle
est sur une case blanche donc elle va à
droite et la casse sur laquelle elle
était devient noir recommence on est sur
une case blanche donc à droite et on
change la case où elle était à nouveau
case blanche à droite et encore case
blanche à droite ont jusqu'ici c'était
pas très fun mais là on est arrivé sur
une case noire donc la fourmi va à
gauche ensuite cases blanches à droite
blanche à droite et blanche à droite
voilà donc après huit mouvements notre
fourmi a changé quelques cases blanches
en cases noires et elle est revenue au
centre de la grille on peut voir ce que
ça va donner si on continue d'appliquer
ces règles de manière répétée alors
comme ça un peu pénible affaire à la
main on va programmer tout ça donc voici
en accéléré ce qui se passe avec les
premiers mouvements de la fourmi vous
voyez qu'en suivant les règles qu'on a
donné notre fourmis se met à dessiner
des jolis motifs et puis voilà je me
suis arrêté à 96 mouvement et vous voyez
que la fourmi est à nouveau revenue au
centre
voilà mais maintenant qu'on a programmé
ça on peut continuer à faire avancer
notre fourmies et regarder ce qui se
passe si on va beaucoup plus loin
donc la fourmi reprend sa marche
et voilà ce qu'on observe voyez qu'elle
continue à dessiner des jolis motifs
plutôt symétrique
en fait ça ressemble un peu à des
espèces de pétales de fleurs
voilà donc là je me suis arrêté à 472
mouvement et on voit que la fourmi elle
est revenue au centre de la griffe alors
elle a dessiné tout au long des jolis
motifs symétriques ce qui est pas très
surprenant parce que nos règles de
départ elles sont quand même assez
symétrique un case blanche à droite case
noire à gauche c'est quand même très
simple sauf que qu'est ce que vous
croyez que ça a vraiment continuer comme
ça tout est bon pour le voir on va faire
la simulation en allant beaucoup plus
loin on va aller jusqu'à 2000 mouvement
alors pour que ça soit clair je vais
dézoomer un petit peu et puis je vais
reprendre la simulation au début vous
êtes prêts allez on y va donc au début
on a vu la fourmi fait des jolis motifs
symétriques et puis une fois qu'on a
passé les 500 premiers mouvements on
dirait qu'elle arrête et même on a
l'impression qu'elle détruit
complètement son joli dessin d'avant et
on voit plus aucun motif symétrique qui
apparaît c'est bizarre non pendant les
500 premiers mouvements notre fourmi a
fait des structures qui étaient très
ordonnée et puis soudainement on a
l'impression qu'elle a perdu son sens de
l'ordre et de l'esthétique et qu'elle se
met à faire des choses qui sont
complètement désordonnée
pourtant on n'a pas changé les règles de
déplacement au milieu un c'est les mêmes
règles de déplacement qu'au début bon là
peut-être que le finir par retomber sur
ses pattes et puis si on fait la
simulation suffisamment loin elle va
finir par reproduire à nouveau des
structures symétrique l1 pour le voir on
va simuler encore beaucoup plus loin on
va aller jusqu'à dix mille mouvement
alors je vais à nouveau des zooms et un
petit peu et puis on va reprendre au
début et puis passer tout ça en accéléré
allez on y va donc motifs réguliers
d'abord là on commence à faire la
symétrie mois et visiblement la fourmi
est devenu un petit peu barjot la
dessine n'importe quoi c'est plutôt le
chaos total
c'est le chaos total alors que tout à
l'heure je vous rappelle on avait un
truc bien ordonné c'est quand même si il
ya eu comme une sorte de transition
voilà et puis ça continue
là on arrive vers dix mille mouvement ah
et puis là il se passe un truc c'est
bizarre vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
attendez je vous le remet un coup là to
tatou sortant du chaos total
notre fourmis se met à construire une
structure parfaitement régulière
parfaitement droite et qui se répètent à
l'infini cette drôle de structure on
l'appelle l'autoroute évidemment à
partir de maintenant on peut continuer
la simulation jusqu'à la fin des temps
il va rien se passer de nouveau un la
fourmi va continuer à dessiner son
autoroute et ça va l'emmener jusqu'à la
faune abondante résume ce qu'on a on a
une fourmi qui se déplacent selon des
règles qui sont absolument enfantine un
gamin de 4 ans avec un papier et un
crayon pourrait simuler le comportement
de la fourmi de l'anc tonnes pendant les
500 premiers mouvements on a des jolies
structure symétrique régulière bien
ordonnée entre 500 et 10000 c'est le
chaos total
et puis à partir d'environ 10000
mouvement une structure complètement
régulière l'autoroute alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ça paraît quand même
incroyable qu'un système aux règles de
base aussi simple puisse engendrer
successivement trois types de
comportements aussi différents et ben en
fait personne comprend vraiment pourquoi
vous allez me dire oui mais on est parti
d'une grille qui était complètement
blanche qu'est ce qui se passe si on
part d'une grille dont certaines cases
sont blanches et d'autres cas ce sont
noirs et ben vous pouvez le faire
et au bout d'un moment pas forcément du
même temps on va toujours retomber sur
l'autoroute en tout cas personne n'a
jamais trouvé de contre-exemple prendra
plus par exemple imaginer qu'il était
possible de trouver des configurations
ou la fourmi suivent un chemin
périodiques où elles reviennent toujours
sur ses pas de la même manière
en fait non ça ça n'existe pas alors la
seule chose qu'on ait réussi à démontrer
c'est que la trajectoire de la fourmi ne
peut pas être borné à dire que la fourmi
va forcément à l'infini d'une manière ou
d'une autre
mais aujourd'hui personne n'a pu
démontrer qu'elle allait forcément en
suivant l'autoroute et avait même des
gens qui se sont amusés à faire des
variantes de la fourmi langton on
utilise plus de deux couleurs de cases
et ben même dans ces cas là on finit
toujours par produire des autoroutes
vous demandez peut-être pourquoi des
gens sérieux comme des chercheurs en
maths ou en informatique s'amuse à
étudier un truc comme la fourmi de
lampes tonnes et bien parce que c'est un
parfait exemple d'un système dont les
règles de base sont très simples mais
dont les comportements sont très
complexes et ce genre de situation c'est
à dire règle simple au niveau
élémentaire et comportements complexes
au niveau global
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve dans
tout un tas de domaines de la science
par exemple en physique statistique pour
expliquer la manière dont certaines
structures de la matière se produisent
ou bien en biologie pour essayer
d'expliquer comment des réactions
chimiques assez simple à la base peuvent
engendrer des choses aussi complexe que
nous d'ailleurs chris langton avait
initialement conçu sa fourmis comme
étant une sorte de système de vie
artificielle vous savez un peu dans
l'esprit du jeu de la ville de conway
donc il faudra je vous parle un jour
mais certaines de ses idées de
simplicité élémentaire complexité global
on les retrouve aussi dans les sciences
humaines comme par exemple en sociologie
ou en économie pour essayer de
comprendre le comportement de groupes de
foule à partir du comportement de ses
constituants élémentaires
toutes ces idées elles constituent un
nouveau domaine d'études scientifiques
qu'on appelle l'émergence l'émergence
c'est donc quelque chose qui est à
l'interface entre les mathématiques la
physique l'informatique la biologie et
les sciences humaines et voyez que même
sur un système super simpliste comme la
fourmi de l'anc tonnes on n'arrive pas à
comprendre l'émergence de structures
complexes
quand je vous dis pas pour comprendre
des phénomènes comme l'apparition de la
vie telle qu'on la connaît et donc les
chercheurs qui travaillent sur ce
domaine de l'émergence
il cherche à créer de nouveaux outils
mathématiques et conceptuel qui
permettrait de comprendre ces phénomènes
et il ya un peu de boulot
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager
comme d'habitude pour m'aider à faire
connaître la chaîne
vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook et twitter vous pouvez
me soutenir sur tipi merci beaucoup à
tous les petits peur qu'ils me
soutiennent et plus vous pouvez aussi me
retrouver sur mon blog sciences éco
nantes
merci à bientôt